cher françois chers amis il ne pouvait
pas être question pour moi de ne pas
être présent même de façon virtuelle
aujourd'hui à votre congrès mais il va
sans dire que la disparition du
président valéry giscard d'estaing
change bien évidemment la teneur de mon
propos du troisième président de la vème
république
vous êtes les héritiers directs et
françois bayrou que je tiens avant toute
chose à féliciter pour sa magnifique
réélection à la tête de votre mouvement
est aujourd'hui le dépositaire
incontesté de cet héritage car c'est à
lui qu'il fut en quelque sorte confiée
par le président valéry giscard
d'estaing lorsque celui-ci pris la
décision de le nommer dès 1989
secrétaire général de l'udf
ce grand parti fondé par le président
giscard d'estaing dans le but de
rassembler deux français sur trois une
volonté qui est aujourd'hui celle de la
majorité présidentielle à laquelle vous
avez souhaité apporter votre précieux
concours
en effet c'est l'ensemble c'est ensemble
que nous devons chercher à rassembler
cette majorité de françaises et de
français qui refusent les clivages
idéologiques ou identitaire au profit du
seul intérêt de notre pays
quarante ans après 1980 l'hommage
unanime qui est rendue par la nation
président élu en 1974 en dit long tout à
la fois sur le bilan de son septennat
bien sûr mais aussi sur la trace de son
action et de sa pensée sur notre vie
politique
c'est lui qui le premier alors même
qu'il était issu d'un milieu très très
10 ionel a compris que la société
française encore très corsetée au moment
de son élection devait évoluer avec son
temps
si la légalisation de l'ivg est géré est
évidemment attaché à la figure
historique et lumineuse de simone veil
jamais elle ne serait parvenu à imposer
cette loi aux forces les plus
conservatrices de la majorité d'alors
sans le soutien indéfectible du
président de la république il me serait
évidemment facile de continuer à
égrainer les réformes que l'on ne
qualifiait pas encore de sociétal à
l'époque et par lesquels le président
giscard d'estaing a fait entrer la
france de plain pied dans la modernité
mais le divorce par consentement mutuel
comme la majorité à 18 ans vient
immédiatement à l'esprit
pour autant si le modem est bien le
dépositaire du testament politique du
président giscard d'estaing c'est
d'abord et avant tout me semble-t-il
celui de la construction européenne dans
laquelle il a joué un rôle majeur qui
est au coeur de votre identité politique
conscient qu'il fallait rapprocher cette
grande idée des peuples il a été le
premier à vouloir démocratiser une
structure politique restait jusque là
strictement inter étatiques
cet homme qui avait participé à la
libération de paris en 1944 connaissait
le prix à payer pour les peuples des
grandes tragédies de l'histoire
ce président visionnaire né à koblenz
qui a su avec son ami le chancelier
helmut schmidt faire du couple franco
allemand
le moteur de l'europe du progrès comment
ne pas voir dans le plan d'eau
relance européen décidé à l'initiative
du président macron et de la chancelière
merkel pour contrecarrer les efforts de
la crise dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui plongée l'héritage direct de
ce souffle et de cette inspiration et
voyez dans l'actualité comme c'est grâce
à l'europe et à sa politique d'achats et
de pré-réservation que nous allons
pouvoir commencer à proposer une
vaccination contre le virus aux
personnes les plus vulnérables
mais le président giscard d'estaing a su
aussi gérer la crise
lui dont le mandat fut contemporain des
deux grands chocs pétroliers qui sont
venus mettre un terme à ces trente
glorieuses qui nous apparaissent
aujourd'hui comme d'un autre temps
la crise elle est toujours là
aujourd'hui
d'abord sanitaires mais aussi économique
social et peut-être même structure et le
modem contribuer avec son courage et ses
exigences à y faire face et je lui suis
profondément reconnaissant du soutien
sans faille qu'il apporte au
gouvernement et à son chef
à l'heure où nous prenons des décisions
difficiles
le présent mignola ce me l'a encore
démontré dans le délicat dossier des
stations de ski
aussi c'est l'occasion pour moi de vous
redire mon profond attachement à la
solidarité de la majorité parlementaire
une solidarité qui s'exprime toujours
dans le cadre du respect légitimes des
prérogatives et de l'identité de chacun
le modem partie des territoires se sont
aussi d'excellents ministre qui oeuvrent
à mes côtés au sein du gouvernement et
sur lesquels je sais pouvoir m'appuyer
sans réserve
le modem
c'est aussi une force de proposition
tourné vers l'avenir car oui nous allons
sortir de cette crise sanitaire et nous
prenons d'ores et déjà toutes les
mesures nécessaires à la réussite de
cette reprise de notre activité
économique culturel et social
indispensable cet avenir commun qu'il
nous faut maintenant des fines et pour
le redressement de la france
c'est à toi mon cher françois qu'il
revient d'en tracer des premiers
contours toi auxquelles le présent de la
république a confié le commissariat au
plan et la mission de renouer avec cette
grande tradition planificatrice
visionnaire et organisatrice de la 4e et
des débuts de la vème république
une tradition qui a donné à la france
les moyens de surmonter les crises
historiques et économiques qu'elle a
traversée depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
une exigence si nous voulons tirer
ensemble toutes les leçons de la période
inédite que nous traversons et des
failles structurelles qu'elle a
brutalement réveillé pour faire face à
cette épidémie qui a fait plus de
cinquante mille morts et menace notre
économie j'ai besoin
mon gouvernement a besoin non seulement
du soutien du modem ou parlement où se
jouera l'essentiel mais aussi de
l'ensemble des forces vives de votre
famille politique
vous êtes ses forces vives et je vous
demande de bien vouloir mettre au
service de la france
votre profonde connaissance votre
connaissance intime du pays
votre grande expérience politique
votre corps de doctrine vos idées vos
propositions
toute cette capacité d'engagement des
hommes et des femmes que vous
représentez et bien sûr
votre force de conviction mon
gouvernement compte évidemment sur vous
je compte sur vous le président de la
république compte sur vous nos
compatriotes compte sur vous plus que
jamais dans ces moments historiques dans
lequel nous nous trouvons
je vous remercie